[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Florence Camoin
directrice du Théâtre Coluche à Plaisir
bonjour bonjour
vous proposer tout au long de l'année
des spectacles tout public et jeunes
publics vous êtes en collaboration avec
la clé des champs pour programmer des
spectacles hors les murs comment s'est
faite cette collaboration avec la clé
des champs écoutez j'ai la chance
d'avoir un ami directeur Frédéric
poletto qui est vraiment un spécialiste
de toutes les musiques actuelles donc je
lui demande beaucoup de conseils voilà
et dès la saison prochaine nous ferons
des événements communs ensemble nous
ouvrirons totalement le bâtiment mais
sache il faudra venir la présentation de
saison 16 juin pour tout savoir quel est
l'intérêt justement des spectacles hors
les murs qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que
ça permet finalement et ça permet de
faire découvrir des salles aux
spectateur finalement parce qu'ils sont
habitués du théâtre Coluche et encore
pas toujours mais en plus on les amène
voir découvrir des spectacles des
nouveautés dans des lieux qui ne
connaissent pas forcément dans leur
ville et ça c'est assez précieux alors
on va parler un petit peu de la
programmation le 12 mai ecos of Prince
nous propose de voyager à travers la
galaxie princière c'est un concert pop
funk on va écouter un extrait et on en
parle juste après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 12 mai au théâtre collé j'ai Coluche
pardon pourquoi avoir choisi ce concert
dans votre programmation ça dépote
carrément quoi les gens ils seront
obligés d'être debout ils vont pas
pouvoir rester assis dans leur siège et
franchement c'est les meilleurs dans la
jeune génération ils sont ils jouent
jusqu'en Angleterre ils jouent dans des
boîtes comme le l'équivalent du New
Morning à Londres ils sont très réputés
ils accompagnent les plus grands mais
franchement faut pas louper ça quoi
c'est vraiment la fête là prince
justement c'est quand même enfin c'est
grand c'est quelqu'un tout le monde
connaît tout le monde Pas tout le monde
est fan mais là pourtant ça pourrait
être une découverte ou une redécouverte
justement exactement moi je suis devenue
fan grâce à ce concert en fait je j'ai
découvert que je connaissais pas que
j'avais des idées préconçues mais
franchement bon tout le monde connaît
Purple Rain mais il y a tellement de
musique avec une inventivité une
dynamique c'est prince oui c'est un
génie et le 26 mai toujours toujours au
théâtre Coluche le spectacle et c'est un
sentiment qu'il faut déjà que nous
combattions je crois le titre est très
évocateur de quoi va-t-on parler lors de
cette soirée c'est vraiment de
journaliste et de manipulation de
l'information
ce titre en fait c'est une phrase de
Roger Gicquel donc dans les années 80
quelquefois il y avait une manipulation
j'espère beaucoup moins aujourd'hui mais
ça ça va permettre aux gens parce que
c'est une communauté de policière autour
d'un reportage qui a été réellement
diffusé je je ne vous en révélerai pas
maintenant le contenu mais pourquoi ça a
été diffusé à cette époque pourquoi ça
ça a un côté manipulateur et qu'est-ce
que on voulait mettre dans la tête des
gens parce que c'est c'est du subliminal
quoi on donne des infos aux gens pour
les manipuler pour leur faire penser
quelque chose donc pourquoi à cette
époque il y a eu ce reportage les
journalistes c'est un peu du cash
investigation
semaine l'enquête pour savoir pourquoi
et ça c'est absolument passionnant puis
c'est une équipe prodigieuse il y a
beaucoup de vidéos on est vraiment
plongé dans une salle de presse c'est
génial on rentre justement à ce
moment-là au cœur au cœur d'une
rédaction journaliste mais pour
déconstruire une vision portée par les
médias le théâtre c'est aussi un lieu
justement où des messages doivent être
transmis au spectateur le théâtre c'est
le lieu où tout est possible c'est le
lieu des voyages c'est le lieu de
l'information c'est le lieu de la
transgression aussi il faut bien le dire
tout est possible au théâtre on est là
pour apporter quand même une vision
peut-être plus poétique plus décalée
pour que les gens puissent réfléchir par
eux-mêmes c'est ça c'est ça qui est
important on peut justement
comment définir cette pièce comme du
théâtre engagé ah je pense que c'est du
théâtre engagé parce qu'il faut oser
dénoncer le rôle des médias parce
qu'aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que pendant
le covid on en a été Abreu pendant un an
et demi
ça devenait une drogue et du jour au
lendemain ça a disparu parce qu'il y a
eu une volonté politique que ça
disparaisse et qu'on en parle plus ça
moi je dis ça c'est une observation
personnelle parce que ça a vraiment
disparu du jour au lendemain mais
réfléchissons ne prenons pas toutes les
infos qu'on voit sur le petit écran
comme argent comptant et renseignant ou
ailleurs et c'est un sentiment qu'il
faut déjà que nous combattu en je crois
c'est donc le 26 mai au théâtre Coluche
et le 3 juin le spectacle les fleurs de
macchabée qu'est-ce qui attend le public
mais écoutez arrêtez d'aller regarder
des chaînes il vous abonner des chaînes
vous avez tout au théâtre vous allez
avoir une vraie série en il y a quatre
épisodes ça va commencer à 13h alors ne
vous inquiétez pas il y a des pauses
vous pourrez vous aurez le temps de
dîner on va on va mettre des food truck
sur le parking on va faire plein de
choses de 13h à 22h on sera ensemble et
vous allez passer un moment magnifique
et pour le prix d'une pièce d'une heure
et demie vous en avez vous allez en
avoir pour 6h réel et 9 heures votre
temps parce qu'il y aura beaucoup
d'entractes et de moments partagés où
vous pourrez échanger avec les gens pour
savoir qui est le coupable pourquoi
machin vitre a fait ceci voilà vous
allez you pouvoir jouer au Cluedo vous
allez pouvoir faire plein de choses et
je crois que l'idée c'est qu'à la fin de
chaque représentation qui dure à peu
près 1h30 à 2h vous allez avoir un
événement qui va se produire et vous
aurez vous serez obligé de rester parce
que vous voudrez savoir la suite si le
principe des séries qu'on voit sur
toutes les sur toutes les plateformes
c'est génial mais prenez le risque moi
je vais à au Festival d'Avignon pendant
pendant trois semaines je vois 7
spectacles par jour donc je de toute
façon les 9h je l'ai fait ça passe très
très bien quand c'est du bon spectacle
c'est parfait les fleurs de ma cabine
donc ça marquera la fin de de cette
saison finalement vous avez voulu faire
participer le public pour cette pour
cette fin de saison
à travers à travers justement le fait où
ils peuvent échanger entre eux etc entre
les emplois une proposition extrêmement
originale il faut prendre des risques
dans la vie et mais franchement si vous
ennuyez au bout d'une heure 30 vous
pouvez partir mais vous allez rester
jusqu'au bout et c'est ça l'éclate c'est
vraiment d'être tous ensemble d'être des
spectateurs et de partager un événement
du commun tous ensemble c'est vraiment
agréable et la nouvelle la nouvelle
saison sera à découvrir le 16 juin vous
l'avez dit en début d'émission quels
sont vos ambitions justement pour la
saison prochaine alors il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'axes ça va être une saison
extrêmement originale d'abord on va
avoir un partenariat avec les scènes
nationales qui va qui nous a proposé de
spectacles de danse on va fêter des
anniversaires il y a plusieurs
anniversaires je peux pas trop dire de
choses mais il y a au moins deux
anniversaires d'importance qui devraient
attirer beaucoup de public il y a des il
y aura deux concerts en partenariat avec
la clé des champs on va ouvrir
totalement le bâtiment il y aura la
problématiques Jeux Olympiques aussi
avec trois spectacles autour du sport
voilà ça va être très original parce que
finalement sur cette saison 23 24 il y a
plein de d'événements qui vont
s'entrecroiser se rencontrer dans ce
théâtre et puis beaucoup de spectacles
familiaux beaucoup plus que les saisons
passées c'est un choix très éclectique
encore plus éclectique que ce que vous
proposez original mais vraiment il y
aura des choses qui ont des spectacles
qui vont vraiment plaire aux gens parce
que ça fait le buzz aussi ça fait déjà
le buzz et vous ouvrez enfin vous
accueillez pardon des artistes en
résidence tout au long de l'année quels
sont les objectifs justement de des
résidences d'artistes moi je veux que
les artistes et le public se rencontrent
pas seulement au moment des
applaudissements pas seulement pendant
le spectacle qui se rencontrent avant et
après le fait de les avoir en résidence
ça permet aux artistes de signaux né le
territoire de rencontrer des publics
relay ça permet de mettre en place
beaucoup beaucoup d'action culturelles
d'ailleurs on va avoir un gros gros
projet de d'action culturelles sur toute
la saison sur un sujet d'actualité même
deux sujets d'actualité extrêmement fort
donc ça pour moi c'est très important
très précieux
donc du coup on vous souhaite justement
une bonne fin de saison déjà parce que
ça va être la fin de saison le 3 juin et
rendez-vous donc le 16 juin pour
découvrir cette cette nouvelle saison
qui débutera début septembre merci
beaucoup Florence Camoin d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice du Théâtre
Coluche à plaisir pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site tekt TEC plaisir.fr et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]